[Music]
we've published apis in the developer
portal
now let's look at monitoring and
analytics
apigee edge includes a number of
built-in analytics charts
the most basic is the traffic volume
chart
here you can see traffic volumes over
time over the week
the day the hour you can also select
custom time periods
all of this is powered by google cloud
analytics so you get
great performance from these charts even
with huge api traffic volumes
that's traffic volume but thinking
outside in
we'd like to understand the experience
users are getting from the apis
what's the response time
here we can see the median response time
as well as the 95th percentile and the
99th percentile
analyzing these trends can help you
identify when your backend services
start to show strain under load
in fact apogee edge analytics can be a
major benefit of apigee edge
even if you don't perform transforms or
apply security in your proxy
this response time insight can be
invaluable as you perform
a b tests or roll out new services
now let's look at error reporting in any
high volume system
there will be errors some are good
errors like 401
when an expired token is presented some
are unexpected
with the error code analysis chart you
can examine error code trends and better
understand
where the errors are occurring and why
this chart can give you that clarity
these are just a few of the analytics
charts that are available out of the box
with apogee edge
and you also have the ability to create
custom reports that show
data you care about which clients are
trending up
which device types show the most errors
how does traffic volume vary over the
course of a day or a week
how effective is the cache which
versions of my api are in low use
that i might deprecate them
using apigee edge analytics gets you
visibility into your api program that
you absolutely need
in order to understand usage and manage
your api efforts